three so first of all I'd say that there
is no such thing as work/life balance it
always feels a little crazy and hectic
and so the idea of you're gonna have
serenity and balancing the two it's just
non-existent I think the thing that I've
learned is it does require extreme
prioritization and focus on what matters
to you and so to that extent it's good
to write it down and focus on I am gonna
be home at these times and I'm gonna do
my work at these times that I'm gonna go
exercise here and I'm gonna be really
anal and rigorous around planning this
otherwise everything else is going to
overtake my life and not let me do those
things when I get home and I try and be
home you know three of the five work
nights a week which doesn't always
happen but I try to I do not turn on my
computer or my iPhone until my kids are
in bed it's just it's a role I don't get
a lot of sleep during the week because
then after I put them in bed I'm up til
the wee hours of the night I'm getting
my work done but you know it's one of
the trade-offs I make and I feel with
that balance I get to I get really good
quality time with my kids every night
and I you know I get my work done when
we work really hard and and it all seems
to work out yeah I think one of the
critical things is to over communicate
and set very very clear goals so my wife
and I were married when we came to
business school and during that two-year
period leave in my class the class of oh
six there was eight couples married
couples who got divorced and for us that
was quite a shock to learn that and to
see that and what we learned through
that is to really communicate very
clearly and aggressively about how we
were doing with one another we have a
red light yellow light green light
methodology where yeah it's it's it's
really simple we can just check in with
each other and when she says things are
yellow I know that I have to slow down
and then the the other very clear goal
is if you set things that you need to do
every day make sure that you're there
and make sure that your partner's know
you need to do it so I have a 10 month
old at home and one of the things that I
do with her everyday is I get home in
time to give her her bath or feed her
dinner give her her bath and put her to
bed and I've managed to do that almost
every single day in the last 10 months
because I said critical
I communicated that to my partners they
understood that was a priority but they
also understood I've had other
responsibilities that I would take care
of on behalf of the firm I'm very proud
of the culture at kleiner and so I'd
like to